la saison dernière à col de moustache on
arrive une nuit non on a pleuré
toi tu as ça donne quoi on attend 6 jeux
à 5 secondes à chanter j'ai mis mon sexe
et la misson quoi je me mets dans un
tupperware honda on a cette année ce
côté moustaches
il y aura gel mais aussi de la bagarre
de l'amour homosexuel
à vous de l'action
ou est-ce qu'il est passé par contre n'y
aura pas mais qu'on galère parce qu'il a
perdu son singe j'ai perdu mon singe
dans le coin où je pense vu que votre
plan hertz et la revue y aura des
caisses de tous
aura pas michel boujenah qui joue de la
flûte traversière à quel rebelles se
michel lerat déplaise à 25% de la
population
ces services étaient le top nickel et
les cornes quelques employés
il n'y aura pas un idiot qui arbitrait
le gouvernement y aura une voix off qui
dit y aura un mec avec un gros nez
du coup il y aura un mec avec un gros
dealer a pas de placement de produit si
mais discret quoi c'est un petit chemin
bordé
en gros il y aura plein de trucs y'aura
pas plein d'autres trucs mais comme les
trucs tu auras passant moins bien que
les trucs y aura et ben on espère que ça
vous plaira
je suis crevée